[Musik]
hey ihr lieben heute gibt es ein mega
einfaches bisher was ich früher als kind
immer ganz gerne gemacht habe meiner
schwester
wir machen ein dessert das ist so ein
bisschen der pudding krämer so wir
kommen uns gleich im pudding und dann
kommt zwieback zum einsatz ist mir
früher immer gemacht später schießen wir
noch ab in der schokoladensauce sehr
simpel aber dennoch sehr lecker und von
jedem immer wieder gemacht und ich mache
jetzt hier so eine art milch pudding ich
hab jetzt hier milch in einem topf und
der herd ist noch nicht an ich gebe
jetzt zuallererst mehr für die bindung
mit ryan dunn natürlich zucker für die
süße und ganz wichtig vanille extrakt
weil ihr müsst euch von uns hat man ja
nur wirklich nur milch zu kamel und
vanille extrakt ist so dieses
ausschlaggebende aroma dieser
ausschlaggebende geschmack damals haben
wir vanillezucker genommen mittlerweile
gibt es ja richtig schön konzentriert
ich verlinke euch mainz in der infobox
und das führt jetzt klümpchen frei
verrührt also wirklich dass gar keine
mehr vorhanden sind und dann erst unter
ständigem rühren aufkochen lassen also
den haag einschalten unseren mit pudding
liegt ein sobald es aufkochen dann ist
es ganz wichtig dass ganz anderen
umzufüllen und dann vollständig
auskühlen lassen am besten mit zugedeckt
an der oberfläche
das dauert auch so eineinhalb bis zwei
stunden gehzeit müsst euch einfach
nehmen weil jetzt kommt steif
geschlagene schlagsahne mit dazu das
habe ich hier schon erledigt einfach
unter rhön und wenn sie jetzt noch warm
wäre dann würde die sonne schmelzen und
das werden nicht so gut und danach gehen
wir auch schon zwieback dazu ich mache
das immer noch mit der hand so ein
bisschen klein und anschließend will sie
eine auflaufform gefüllt
[Musik]
auf die zwieback pudding schicht kommt
jetzt noch eine schokosoße und dafür
ganz einfach sahne erhitzen ganz
vorsichtig dass der topf hohen mich an
brennt dann vollmilchschokolade
reingeben und miteinander verschmelzen
lassen das ganze dass die zehn minuten
stehen damit vielleicht abkühlt und gibt
es dann auf die pudding schicht und
danach könnt ihr dekorieren wie ihr
möchtet ich habe jetzt ein mangel
krokant genommen ich liebe markant ihr
könnt auch kokosnuss nehme also
kokosraspeln oder zum beispiel pistazien
oder ihr lasst es pur ganz wie ihr
möchtet wichtig ist dass das ganze jetzt
nochmal zum kühlen für drei stunden in
den kühlschrank kommt dann ändert sich
auch noch einmal so ein bisschen was
eine konsistenz und ihr werdet merken
das ist alles ein bisschen leicht fest
und cremiger wird und dann könnte es
einfach nur genießen und das ist so ein
rezept das mache ich gerne wenn zum
beispiel schwiegerfamilie kommt oder
meine familie oder alle zusammen
guckt mal da können ganz viele von essen
und es ist günstig es ist ja wirklich so
wäre man auch wenig zutaten hier
überhaupt heute und es können echt mega
viel davon essen wir beide freuen uns
dann morgen graut dass wir das
verspeisen und jetzt nicht jetzt weil
wie gesagt drei stunden können es sei
denn du willst um 0 uhr nachts machen
kuchen essen dann können dann können wir
das auch machen euch jetzt ganz viel
freude beim nachmachen schreibt auf
jeden fall in die kommentare wie es euch
gefallen habe wenn es danach gemacht
habt nicht vergessen bei mir immer in
der video beschreibung schauen da stehen
die ganzen mengenangabe und alles was
ich so ein video verwendet habe und dann
freue ich mich wenn ihr in meinem video
ein dörfchen nach oben da lassen und
mich kostenlos abonniert hat fast ihr
solch geniale rezepte auch nicht mehr
und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem
nächsten rezept wieder ciao ciao und wie
[Musik]
und schmeckt so kann man noch mal machen
das nicht sie hören rezepte wenn man im
juden besucht hatten
und irgendwie hat ja mehrere
verschiedene ist ein typisches
verschieden ist sehr hart wird und des
einkommens zu hören ja zur album schnell
einfach und schnell und wann kommst
online demnächst wie gesagt wir haben
wirklich geile der titel für euch vor
gedreht